a bucear es uno de los mayores placeres
para los que disfrutan del mar sin
embargo el objetivo de este grupo de
buceadores es dejarlo de hacer en medio
de una ola de basura que invade las
aguas en una playa de filipinas pañales
viejos botellas plásticas redes de pesca
y otros desechos amenazan la vida marina
de essalud a pequeña escala a la gente
que bucea no le cuesta nada recoger lo
que encuentran porque el impacto de
tener esa bolsa de plástico en el agua
es mucho mayor de verdad es un impacto
enorme
en la capital italiana muchas personas
también se congregaron para conmemorar
el día mundial de la limpieza celebrado
en 180 países como aseguran los
organizadores del evento
hoy nos comprometemos a restaurar este
hermoso lugar recogiendo basura cortando
el césped y revitalizando la belleza de
este sitio
en esta playa de ciudad del cabo grupos
ambientalistas se reunieron para recoger
plástico y otros desechos
la actividad se replicó en sarajevo
donde la ola de limpieza mundial se
organizó en las calles de varias
ciudades y en la región montañosa del
país aquí
vine a limpiar la montaña esto tiene
mucha importancia para nosotros pero
tiene todavía mucha basura debido a la
gente que camina por aquí todo el tiempo
[Música]
desde 2013 un proyecto de gran
envergadura llamado ocean clean up
elimina basura plástica del pacífico a
través de esta enorme red en 120 horas
de despliegue en el mes de agosto la red
recogió cerca de 8,2 toneladas de
plástico sin embargo los barcos
utilizados para la operación liberan
emisiones de efecto invernadero pero la
fundación detrás del proyecto asegura
que están experimentando con
biocombustibles menos contaminantes
según un reporte del foro económico
mundial si el flujo de plástico hacia el
océano no para tendrá más masa plástica
que peces para 2050